Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton faced
off in the first presidential debate of
the season here it is in three minutes
they were both terrible in their own
unique ways Trump talked a lot about law
and order and touted New York City's
rights violating stop-and-frisk policy
we have to bring back law and order now
whether or not in a place like Chicago
you do stop and frisk which worked very
well mayor Giuliani is here worked very
well in New York it brought the crime
rate way down of course
crime rates were going down before stop
and frisk went down during stop and
frisk have continued to go down after
New Yorkers right to walk down a
sidewalk without being intimately
touched by an armed agent of the state
was restored Clinton's response was to
point a gun we've got too many
military-style weapons on the streets in
a lot of places our police are outgunned
despite the fact that gun violence is
also at an all-time low
nationwide most people watching the
debate are going to remember where the
candidates disagreed but to libertarians
perhaps the more disturbing areas are
those where the candidates are in
agreement even though Trump talked a big
game about debt reduction we owe 20
trillion dollars 20 trillion in debt
we're a debtor nation both agreed that
we just don't spend enough let's have
paid family leave Trump tried to outdo
Hillary's 30 billion a year family leave
government mandate as far as child care
is concerned and so many other things I
think Hillary and I agree on that with
his own family leaf plan and other
spending proposals that would increase
the debt by 11 and a half trillion
dollars over ten years unlike Trump
Clinton acknowledged the possibility
that international trade is a good thing
well I think that trade is an important
issue of course we are five percent of
the world's population we have to trade
with the other ninety five percent but
after the primary campaign both
candidates now agree that the deals we
have are killing us you want to approve
trans-pacific partnership you were
totally in favor of it then you heard
what I was saying how bad it is and you
said I can't win that debate that that
is just not accurate I was against it
once it was finally negotiated leaving
nobody on stage to defend the principle
of free trade you're too dangerous to
fly you are too dangerous to buy a gun
the most egregious area of total
agreement was on the issue of gun rights
and government lists pass a prohibition
on
one who's on the terrorist watchlist
from being able to buy a gun in our
country I think we have to look very
strongly at no-fly lists and watch lists
and when people are on there even if
they shouldn't be on there will help
them will help them legally will help
them get off once again Americans didn't
get a chance to hear a principled
argument about individual rights the
Constitution and due process while the
debate had its fair share of strange and
entertaining moments I call it
trumped-up trickle-down I will release
my tax returns against my lawyer's
wishes when she releases her 33,000
emails that have been deleted as soon as
she releases them I will release I will
release my tax returns and that's
against my lawyers they say don't do it
American voters were cheated out of a
full debate that represents the true
diversity of political thought and
opinion that exists in this country
instead they got what they almost always
get the chance to choose between two bad
candidates
you